المصريون في غزه وفي تلبيب ايضا تحرك حثيث
لوفد امني مصري يمضي ساعات في غزه ومثلها
في اسرائيل الهدف المعلن هو استعاده
التهدئه في غزه السياق هو تحذير دوائر
امنيه وعسكريه اسرائيليه من مواجهه عسكريه
وانفجار الاوضاع في الاراضي المحتله وهو
سيناريو لا يود نتنياهو ان يراه على اعتاب
انتخابات تشريعيه يواجه فيها خصوما يريدون
توترا امنيا يستخدمونه حجه للتدليل على
ضعف سياسه الحكومه الامنيه في ذات الوقت
لا يريد رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه ان يدفع
ثمنا للتهدئه يصنفه في خانه الخاضع لشروط
حماس قبل استحقاق الانتخابات ماذا عن شروط
حماس قياده المقاومه تطالب بالعوده الى
التفاهمات السابقه بين الجانبين والتي
تقضي برفع الحصار وكسره بشكل نهائي تقرير
هبه
عكيله مهمه مكوكيه جديده بين غزه واسرائيل
بداها وفد مصري بقياده وكيل جهاز
المخابرات العام مع عمر حنفي فقد اجرى
الوفد الامني المصري جوله ثانيه من
المباحثات في اسرائيل بخصوص الوضع في قطاع
غزه جاء ذلك بعد اجتماع في غزه مع قاده
حركه حماس برئاسه اسماعيل هانيه ويحيى
السنوار واستنادا الى مصادر فلسطينيه ركز
اجتماع غزه اساسا على مساله التهدئه وطلبت
حماس من خلال الوفد المصري التزام اسرائ
بالاتفاق المبرم بين الطرفين مسبقا والذي
يقضي برفع الحصار
كليا في حين تحدثت مصادر اسرائيليه
وفلسطينيه عن ان الوفد المصري نقل من
اسرائيل رساله الى قياده حماس تشترط وقف
كل اشكال الانشطه في مسيرات العوده خاصه
البالونات الحارقه
والمتفجرة
القطريه ونقل الوفد المصري كذلك من خلال
حركه حماس الى الفصائل الفلسطينيه في غزه
رغبه اسرائيل في العوده الى تطبيق تفاهمات
الهدوء التي كانت المخابرات المصريه قد
توصلت اليها بين اسرائيل وحماس قبل نحو
خمسه اشهر والتزامها بتنفيذ تعهداتها
مقابل وقف كل المظاهر التي وصفها بالخشن
التي ترافق مسيره
العوده عاد الوفد المصري الى اسرائيل
الثلاثاء وعقد اجتماعات مع وفد برئاسه
رئيس المساد على ان يعود ثانيه الى غزه
الخميس حاملا الرد الاسرائيليه على مطالب
الفصائل
الفلسطينيه مهمه الوفد الامني المصري تاتي
في ظل سياق متشابك سواء ما يتعلق
بالحسابات الانتخابيه الاسرائيليه او وفر
عوامل قد تدفع الى تدهور الاوضاع نحو
مواجهه عسكريه واسعه النطاق كثيرا ما تهدد
او تلوح بها اطراف اسرائيليه فاست انادا
الى جهات اسرائيليه هناك اوراق لا تريد
اسرائيل خسارتها ومن جانب الفصائل
الفلسطينيه هناك اوراق قد تحسن فرص
التهدئه
فالفائدة الاولى لمسيرات العوده وانتخابات
اسرائيليه على الابواب وهو ما قد يجبر
حكومه نتنياهو على تقديم تسهيلات جديده
للقطاع وتنفيذ مشاريع وعد بها المبعوث
الاممي نيكولاي ميلادينوف
في المقابل قد تخالف اوضاع اسرائيل قبل
الانتخابات التوقعات بتنفيذ اتفاق التهدئه
مع غزه نظرا الى التخوف من وجود تاثيرات
اليمين الاسرائيلي في المشهد
الانتخابي نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيفنا من
غزه الدكتور عدنان ابو عامر استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه الامه بغزه ومع ضيفنا
من القاهره مجدي شندي رئيس تحرير صحيفه
المشهد الاسبوعيه اهلا بكما وابدا معك
دكتور عدنان ما هي الارضيه التي انطلقت
منها جوله الوفد الامني المصري بين غزه
واسرائيل هذه
المره مساء الخير مريم وساده المشاهدين
الحقيقه ان الجهود المصريه مع حماس
واسرائيل مجتمعه في حاله سباق مع الزمن ان
صح التعبير الكل يدرك ان هذه الاسابيع
المتبقيه من الانتخابات الاسرائيليه تبدو
حرج جدا وكل طرف يريد تحقيق انجازات خاصه
به مصر لا تريد تدهور اوضاع في قطاع غزه
على حدودها الشرقيه و وسيناء حماس تعتقد
ان هذه فرصه ذهبيه لا تعوض قبيل
الانتخابات الاسرائيليه تحصل انجازات
السياسيه من اسرائيل اسرائيل ترى ان تقديم
اي تنازلات لحماس في هذا الوقت يعني خص
الصفوف معسكر اليمين هذه المصالح الت
متناقضه بين اطراف الثلاثه بموجبها يمشي
المصريون في هذه الوساطه الحاليه لكن هل
مساله نجاح ام لا هذا مره بال التوقعات
الامنيه الحاصله في هذه اللحظات هناك
اطلاق نار من قبل الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه
واستمرار ح الارباك الليلي باطلاق البين
الحارقه ولذلك الاوضاع الميدانيه جدا
حساسه وحرجه ولا احد يضمن ان يكون هذه
الجهود ناجحه هذه المره مثل سابقاتها في
ظل هذه الظروف سيد مجدي شندي و وما وصفه
ضيفنا من غزه الدكتور عدنان بالمصالح
المتناقضه بين اسرائيل وغزه من جهه والوفد
المصري الذي يقوم بهذه الجولات المكوكيه
الان هل يمكن للوفد المصري ان يقدم جديدا
او افكارا جديده خلال هذه المرحله لربما
اعاده بعض ما تم تعطيله من التفاهمات
السابقه يعني الوفد المصري يضغط ويقوم
بجولات مكوكيه من اجل تح حقيق المطالب
الفلسطينيه التي نص
عليها تفاهمات نصت عليها تفاهمات التهدئه
قبل شهور بواسطه مصر وبواسطه الامم
المتحده اسرائيل تود من جانبها وقف وحدات
الارباك الليلي وهذا ينبغي ان يكون له ثمن
الثمن يتمثل في تخفيف الضغوط عن
الاقتصاديه على قطاع غزه وا اتاحه يعني
دخول البضائع وتطبيق ما تم الاتفاق عليه
قبل ذلك وحنث به اسرائيل
وبالتالي القياده المصريه ترى ان هذا هو
وقت ملائم
لانتزاع مكاسب من اسرائيل لصالح
الفلسطينيين الذين يقعون تحت حصار
اسرائيلي بشع وا هناك مقترحات
محدده تختص
ب يعني توسيع منطقه الصيد في قطاع غزه
وادخال البضائع
وبعد فتره يجري بحث الميناء والمطار و اذا
كانت اسرائيل تريد تهدئه فلتدخل ثمن ذلك
دكتور عدنان الوفد المصري سيعود الى غزه
غدا ليلتقي قاده حماس وسيكون قادما من
اسرائيل طبعا هل لديك فكره عما يمكن ان
ترد به حماس على تلك الشروط
الاسرائيليه شوفي مريم تقديرا واكراما
للجهود المصريه لكنها تقترب كثيرا من
التوصيف انها طفات حرائق الجهد المصري
الاصلي ينبغي ان يكون قبيل حدوث اي توتر
ميداني امني بمعنى انه عدم استدعاءه عند
حصول التوترات ثم يطفئ هذا التدهور الحاصل
تبادل رسائل الحاصل بين حماس واسرائيل عبر
وسطه مصر يا كريمه واضح انه لن يحقق نتائج
جيده جدا على هذه المرحله ما قد يحصل هو
ترقيع للامر القائم محاوله تحسينات طفيفه
بسيطه قد لا يشعر بها الفلسطيني في قطاع
غزه ومحاوله اسرائيليه واضحه واضحه لشراء
وقت اضافي الى حين يوم التاسع من ابريل
القادم لانتخابات اسرائيليه المصريون
بامكانهم ان يمارسوا ضغوط اكثر على
اسرائيل لتحسين شروط تفاوض الفلسطينيه
وانتزاع منهم تنازلات خاصه بالوضع المعيشي
الاقتصادي بقطاع غزه لكن واضح ان هناك
حسابات كما تعلم مين الكل معني في هذه
المرحله بان تبقى حماس في حاله لا تحيا
ولا تموت ومعها غزه بالتاكيد ولا يحد يريد
ان يعطيها طوق النجاح صح التعبير من هذه
الازمه الاقتصاديه الحاصله لذلك ما يحصل
من جهود مصريه الى حد ما هو جهود الى حد
تاتي في اطار اداره الازمه الحاصله وليست
تح ايجاد نتائج ايجابيه جديده لهذه الازمه
اذا الجهود المصريه تتركز على اداره
الازمه الراهنه هذا ما يقوله ضيفنا دكتور
عدنان من غزه سيد مجدي شندي والفصائل
الفلسطينيه تطالب كذلك القاهره بالضغط على
تل ابيب للالتزام باجراءات تخفيف الحصار
نتساءل هنا اين تقف
القاهره في هذه الجولات التي تقوم بها بين
غزه واسرائيل وما الذي يمكن ان تقدمه ربما
لتحريك ما هو عاطل ان كان من التفاهمات
السابقه او من تفاهمات يمكن طرحها خلال
هذه
الجوله يعني القاهره تقف دائما في
صف المطالب الفلسطينيه ومع تحقيق ما يريده
الفلسطينيون
من حل ازماتهم الاقتصاديه تقليل الحصار او
وقف الحصار على قطاع غزه انتزاع كل ما
يمكن من حقوق فلسطينيه لان يعني
الفلسطينيين
لديهم قضيه
ولهم حقوق تاريخيه ينبغي انت تتحقق والان
حتى وان كانت الظروف غير مواتيه يمكن ان
يحظوا حتى بالحد الادنى الذي يحقق لهم عيش
حياه كريمه
و فح قطاع غزه وعدم تحويله الى يعني بؤره
لكيف يمكن ان تساهم مصر في ذلك سيد
مجدي نعم كيف يمكن ان تساهم مصر ايضا في
ذلك وهي التي تغلق معبر رفح
لا معبر رفح ليس مغلقا وانما مفتوحا طالما
انه ليس هناك اي تهديد
امني يتعلق ب سيناء ويتعلق بالجانب المصري
واعتقد ان التفاهمات بين مصر وحماس قائمه
منذ عام 2016 حتى هذه اللحظه ولا يقدم
الفلسطينيون اي شكاوه من
بالعكس حتى تم الافراج عن معتقلين كانوا
محتجزين في مجدي شدي وبتالي العلاقات
علاقات حسنه بين مصر وقطاع غزه وبين
السلطه المصريه وحماس اريد ان اسال دكتور
عدنان عن معطى الانتخابات الاسرائيليه
المقبله والتي ربما تشكل ضغطا على رئيس
الوزراء نتنياهو خلال هذه المرحله ما
يدفعه ربما الى تقديم تنازلات ما حجم هذه
التنازلات وما اقصى ما يمكن ان تحصل عليه
حماس لقاء
ذلك وقد تجعله اكثر تشددا وعدم تقديم
تنازلات نعم المرحله الانتخابيه الحاصله
هذه مرحله انتخابيه يعني تسمى حاميه
الوطيس هناك استقطاب سياسي حزبي في
اسرائيل عز نظيره في العقود الاخيره ونسب
تكان متقارب بين معسكر اليمين الاسرائيلي
ومعسكر الوسط ان صح التعبير بقده
الجنرالات الاسرائيليين اي تقديم اي اشاره
اسرائيليه تصعيدا او هبوطا تنازلا ام
تشددا مع الفلسطينيين تترجم تلقائيا ب
اطلاعات الراي لصالح اليمين او ضده ولذلك
نتنياهو حذر جدا جدا لن الان عينه على عين
على غزه وعين على صندوق الاقتراع في يوم
التاسع من ابريل لذلك اي حراك سياسي معين
تجاه الفلسطيني في قطاع هناك حسابات
انتخابيه اكثر من حسابات سياسيه بعده
المدى ولذلك هو يكون يدير ازمه قطاع غزه
ولتك دكتور عدان دكتور عدنان ابو عامر
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الامه
بغزه ومجد رئيس تحرير صحيفه المشهد
الاسبوعيه من القاهره شكرا جزيلا لكما
وشكرا لمتابعتكم ملفات الحصاد لهذه الليله
الى
اللقاء